salut les épicurieuses et les épicurieux
faut-il mettre de l'huile dans l'eau de
cuisson des pâtes j'en vois certains qui
lève les bras au ciel et d'autres qui
sourit la question divise les pâtes et
l'huile ce n'est pas le seul sujet en
cuisine sur lequel les avis divergent je
vous donne CIN trucs infaillibles qui
vont faire de vous de véritables cordons
[Musique]
ble pour réussir les pâtes il faut des
pâte bien sûr fraîche ou sèche une
casserole pleine d'eau et un peu de sel
certains vous diront qu'il faut aussi
ajouter un peu d'huile dans l'eau de
cuisson ils sont convaincus qu'une fois
dans l'eau l'huile entre en contact avec
les pâtes ce qui les empêche de coller
imagine très bien l'huile enrobant les
pâtes comme le fromage enrobe un morceau
de pain quand on fait de la fondue sauf
que c'est complètement faux regarder
dans la casserole l'huile reste en
surface et vous savez pourquoi c'est
parce que l'huile et l'eau ne se mélange
pas l'huile est hydrophobe elle n'aime
pas l'eau on dit que l'eau et l'huile ne
sont pas missibles et si l'huile reste
en surface c'est parce qu'elle est moins
dense que l'eau donc elle ne rentrera
pas en contact avec les pâtes qui elles
sont plonger dans l'eau et elle ne
pourra pas les empêcher de coller bah du
coup l'huile je peux la mettre au
placard et non car l'huile peut-être
très utile mais juste après la cuisson
une fois les pâtes estgûté de l'huile
d'olive cette fois l'huile entre en
contact avec les pâtes et elle ne colle
pas si vous n'aimez pas le goût de
l'huile d'olive vous pouvez la remplacer
par une noisette de beurre ou bien une
sauce une sauce tomate par exemple qui
si elle a été bien préparée contient un
peu de matière grasse de l'huile ou du
beurre indispensable pour la cuisson des
oignons ou des échalotes qui entrent
dans la composition de la sauce mais
alors du coup je la garde l'huile
l'huile normalement c'est pour le goût
pour que les pâtes ne collent pas il y a
une autre technique
il faut les faire cuire dans un grand
volume d'eau idéalement 1 L pour 100 g
de pâtes mais pourquoi autant d'eau les
pâtes sont faites à partir de farine de
blé du blé qui contient beaucoup
d'amidon c'est l'amidon relâché par les
pâtes qui au moment de la cuisson
favorise leur agglomération or en noyant
les pâtes dans un grand volume d'eau et
bien on dilu l'aminon et on les empêche
de coller les unes aux autres et puis on
surveille aussi la cuisson plus cuise
plus elle rejette de l'amidon plus elle
risque de coller vous le voyez pas
besoin d'huile pour cuire les pâtes
juste un peu après pour le goût oh mince
la date est dépassée poubelle il ne faut
pas le jeter un œuf reste consommable
jusqu'à 1 mois après sa date de
consommation recommandée ce qu'on
appelle la
DCR c'est écrit sur la coquille de l'œuf
en rouge
DCR avec une date juste à côté à
condition bien sûr que la coquille ne
soit pas fêée si vous avez un petit
doute il existe un test très simple pour
savoir si l'œuf peut être consommé ou
non pour cela il vous suffit de remplir
un récipient avec de l'eau et de plonger
l'œuf dedans ensuite vous observez son
comportement c'est lui qui est un peu
fêé non pas du tout si l'œuf coule comme
ici cela signifie que l'œuf est bien
frais et que vous pouvez le manger sans
aucun problème en revanche
s'il flotte à la surface comme celui-ci
c'est que l'œuf est trop vieux en
vieillissant la coquille de l'œuf
s'abîme elle devient de plus en plus
poreuse et l'œuf se déshydrate une
partie de l'eau contenue dans le blanc
s'évapore tandis que l'air pénêtre à
l'intérieur et prend la place de l'eau
qui s'est échappé résultat le flotte
comme une bouée mais comme l'air
favorise aussi le développement de
certaines bactéries il ne faut pas le
consommer enfin un dernier cas de figure
lorsque l'œuf se positionne à la
verticale qu'il flotte entre deux eau
cela signifie qu'il n'est plus tout à
fait frais mais qu'il reste encore
consommable n'attendez pas trop quand
même faites-le bien cuire il faut le
manger à la coque par exemple ou
l'utiliser pour la préparation d'un
gâteau au passage je vous invite à
contrôler régulièrement la dessert de
vos œufs et de les consommer avant qu'il
soit trop tard c'est vrai que c'est
dommage de jeter un œuf la poule c'est
quand même un peu cassé le pour le
pondre oh ça pique oh je m'y ferai
jamais vous aussi ça vous est sûrement
déjà arrivé mais pourquoi pleure-t-on
quand on coupe un oignon quand la lame
pénètre dans le bulbe des milliers de
cellules qui le composent sont percés le
liquide qu'elle contiennent se retrouve
à l'air Liv ce liquide contient des
composants souffrés qui au contact de
l'air se transforme en gaz en oxyde de
propaneéthial ce gaz se diffuse très
facilement autour de l'oignon jusqu'à
atteindre notre visage jusque là tout va
bien mais en arrivant au niveau de nos
yeux il réagit avec le liquide lacrymal
il se transforme alors en acide
sulfurique quoi de l'acide sulfurique
panique les quantités produites ne sont
pas suffisantes pour présenter un
quelconque danger en revanche nos yeux
sont irrités du coup ils se défendent
nos glandes lacrymales se mettent à
produire des larmes pour les nettoyer
sauf que plus on pleure plus l'oxyde de
propanétial a de quoi réagir plus on
fabrique de l'acide sulfurique c'est un
véritable cercle vis pour que ça se
calme il suffit d'arrêter de couper les
oignons et d'attendre que les larmes est
assez coulé pour éliminer les composant
irritant mais pour éviter ce désagrément
il existe quand même quelques astuces te
fatigue pas j'ai trouvé un truc bonne
idée mais à condition que tes lunettes
de plongé soi bien hermétique le
problème c'est que tout le monde n'a pas
des lunettes de plongé à porter de main
dans sa cuisine moi je préfère utiliser
un couteau bien aiguisé un couteau qui
coupe très bien en réalisant des coupes
nettes on perce beaucoup moins de
cellules remplies de liquide et
forcément on libère moins de composé
souffré dans l'air on peut aussi couper
l'oignon sous un filet d'eau juste à
proximité au contact de l'eau le gaz
irritant se transforme en acide
sulfurique qui s'écoule directement dans
l'évier sans atteindre nos yeux l'autre
solution c'est de placer l'oignon une
vingtaine de minutes au congélateur au
moment de le couper le liquide a
commencé à se figer et il y a donc moins
d' de composer sous frrais malin non
elle est pas fraîche et les invités qui
arrivent dans une demi-heure vite au
fraiseer c'est un réflexe logique mais
il y a une meilleure solution pour
refroidir rapidement une bouteille de
champagne dans un freeer la température
atteint - 18° or à cette température il
faut environ 1 heure à une bouteille qui
se trouve au départ à température
ambiante autrement dit aux alentours de
20° pour descendre à 8 10° la
température idéal pour consommer du
champagne si vos invités arrivent dans
la demi-heure votre bouteille ne sera
pas fraîche c'est foutu on boira du
champomis pas de panique j'ai la
solution pour refroidir la bouteille en
quelques minutes il vous faut de la
glace du sel et de l'eau les trois en
quantité égale ici 500 g de
chaque on verse le tout dans un saut à
champagne ou dans un grand saladier si
on n pas de saut et ensuite on plonge la
bouteille dans le saut vous allez voir
en moins de 10 minutes le contenu de la
bouteille va descendre aux alentours de
8 10°gr c'est le résultat d'un phénomène
bien connu regardez quand je mélange du
sel avec de l'eau le sel se dissou les
ions chlorure et sodium qui constitue le
sel se dissocie au contact des molécules
d'eau et pour que cette dissolution ait
lieu il faut de l'énergie et bien cette
énergie est directement puisée dans
l'eau sous forme de chaleur si on pompe
de la chaleur dans l'eau ça sa
température finit logiquement par
diminuer mais pour que le sel se
dissocie avec de la glace il faut encore
plus d'énergie en effet le sel se
dissocie dans l'eau liquide donc il faut
d'abord que la glace fonde ce qui
consomme là aussi de l'énergie sous
forme de chaleur donc sous nos yeux dans
ce saut se déroule en ce moment même
deux processus qui puisent de la chaleur
le passage de l'état solide à liquide de
l'eau qu'on appelle la fusion et la
dissolution du sel la température de
l'eau va donc descendre très bas et très
rapidement on est déjà à - 3° - 7° -9° -
10° et ça peut descendre jusqu'à - 21
alors vous allez me dire il fait à peu
près la même température dans le freezer
sauf que dans le freeer la bouteille est
en contact avec de l'air alors que dans
le saau à champagne elle est en contact
avec de l'eau et que les échanges
thermiques sont plus efficaces dans
l'eau que dans l'air voilà pourquoi la
bouteille va refroidir plus vite dans le
soie champagne dans freeer oh ils ont
pas tout
bu le
problème c'est que je ne peux pas
remettre le bouchon pas de panique j'ai
une solution c'est ma grand-mère qui m'a
appris ce truc il suffit de placer une
cuillère dans le goulot de la bouteille
stop mais il raconte vraiment n'importe
quoi ça ne marche pas du tout ce truc
des scientifiques se sont même penchés
sur la question en 1995 des chercheurs
du Centre interprofessionnel des vins de
Champagne ont voulu vérifier si ce geste
avait un fond de vérité pour cela ils
ont débouché simultanément une douzaine
de bouteilles de champagne qu'ils n'ont
pas vidé de leur contenu ils les ont
ensuite séparé en plusieurs lots trois
lots un premier lot de bouteille muni de
petites cuillères dans le goulot un
deuxième lot avec des bouteilles
rebouché et enfin un troisème sans
bouchau ces différentes bouteilles ont
été ensuite pesées 24 48 puis 72 he afin
de mesurer la perte de gaz carbonique la
perte de bullle si vous préf bah oui si
les bulles s'échappent les bouteilles
deviennent plus légères c'est logique
leur conclusion a été sans appel le
champagne conservé à la petite cuillère
s'est évaporé tout aussi vite que celui
à l'air libre en revanche les bouteilles
munies de bouchon ont conservé leur
bulles un peu plus longtemps celà dit
après 48 he toutes les bouteilles
avaient perdu toutes leurs bulles même
celle avec un bouchon enfin bon la
grand-mère elle l'a quand même pas
inventé ce truc en fait cette croyance
vient du milieu de la restauration on
dit qu'autrefois cela permettait de
différencier les bouteilles contenant
encore un peu de champagne de celle qui
étit complètement vide certaines
personnes ont pensé à tort que c'était
une astuce secrète pour conserver le
champagne débouchonné bon ben alors
champagne c'est tout pour aujourd'hui si
ces sujets vous intéressent n'hésitez
pas à nous proposer d'autres idées
reçues sur la cuisine j'auris plaisir à
les digérer et à vous les servir sur un
plateau à très
bientôt
[Musique]